انتقل الان الى تطورات في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه المحتله حيث حشدت شرطه
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي نحو الفين من افرادها
في انحاء مدينه القدس والبلده القديمه
ومحيطها في الجمعه الثانيه من شهر رمضان
المبارك مع بدء تدفق عشرات الاف
الفلسطينيين الى المسجد الاقصى لاداء
الصلاه كما عزز جيش الاحتلال قواته على
الحواجز العسكريه بين الضفه الغربيه
والقدس
هذا وكان قد اعلن فيه السابق عن قيود
ستحول دون تمكن الرجال ممن هم دون الخامس
والاربعين عاما من عبور الحواجز اعلن
مناسق واعمال الاحتلال في الحكومه
الاسرائيليه انه سيسمح لعدد محدود من سكان
قطاع غزه بدخول القدس وسيشمل ذلك الرجال
ممن تجاوزوا 55 والنساء ممن تجاوزنا
الخمسين عاما
معنا من جبل الزيتون في القدس مراسل
الجزيره الياس كرام الياس هذه الاجراءات
وتعزيزات العسكريه الاسرائيليه كيف تؤثر
حتى الان على تدفق المصلين الفلسطينيين
هي تؤثر بشكل سلبي بطبيعه الحال ذلك ان
الكثير من الفلسطينيين يطوقون الى الوصول
الى مدينه القدس واداء صلاه الجمعه
الثانيه في رمضان لكن رغم ما اعلنه
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي من تسهيلات كما
يسميها لكن هنالك قيود تفرض بالفعل على
حركه الفلسطينيين تحديدا اولئك الذين
ياتون من محافظات الضفه الغربيه المحتله
عبر الحواجز العسكريه التي تبدو مقتظه هذا
الصباح بعشرات الاف الفلسطينيين الذين
يتوجهون صوب مدينه القدس لاداء الصلاه
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي كانت اعلنت عن
قيود وحددت اعمارها من سيسمح لهم بالدخول
الى مدينه القدس لاداء اسرار لكن رغم ذلك
حتى ان الاعمار الذين يسمح لهم بالدخول
ربما في بعض الاحيان يواجهون مشكله في
عبور الحواجز التي يفرضها الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي في مناطق عده لكن مع ذلك
التوقعات ازداد الاعداد هذا الاسبوع
مقارنه مع الاسبوع السابق في الاسبوع
السابق توجه نحو 100 الف فلسطيني او
تمكنوا من الوصول على الاقل الى المسجد
الاقصى المبارك وادو الصلاه التوقعات هذه
الجمعه بان تكون الاعداد اكبر من ذلك
التقديرات كانت في الاسبوع الماضي بان نحو
30,000 فلسطيني من محافظات الضفه الغربيه
المحتله تمكنوا بالفعل من اجتياز الحواجز
العسكريه وبلوغ مدينه القدس نتوقع هذا
الاسبوع وربما ان تزداد الاعداد اكثر
بالمجمل العام الاجواء هادئه
والفلسطينيون يتدفقون الى المسجد الاقصى
المبارك بسلاسه نحن نتحدث عن الفلسطينيين
من الضفه الغربيه المحتله ومن القدس وكذلك
من الفلسطينيين من القرى والبلدات العربيه
في داخل الخط الاخضر الذين ياتون ايضا
لاعمار المسجد الاقصى والصلاه فيه
والاعتكاف في بعض
الاحيان الامور بالمجمل العام هادئه قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي فرضت
طوقا شاملا على البلده القديمه تحديدا
ووضعت الحواجز للتامين دخول الحافلات الى
مقربه من المسجد الاقصى المبارك وانزال
الفلسطينيين هناك نتحدث عن نحو 2300 عنصر
من عناصر الشرطه المنتشره في ثلاث حلقات
امنيه في البلده القديمه على ابواب المسجد
الاقصى وعلى مداخل البلده القديمه وكذلك
الامر في الضواحي لكن تبقى الانظار متجهه
الى الاسبوع المقبل حيث سيبدا اليهود ايضا
بالاحتفال بما يسمى الفصحى اليهودي وتبقى
الانظار متجهه نحو الاقتحامات التي ربما
سينفذها هؤلاء في المسجد الاقصى المبارك
بالتزامن مع الصلوات في المسجد الاقصى
المبارك ودعوات بعض المتطرفين الى تقديم
القرابين فيما يعرب عشيه الفصح من جبل
الزيتون في القدس شكرا جزيلا لك